what can you do from a marketing
perspective to take your you know new
idea from zero dollars to a million I
pull what are the things you got to do
yes so you know business is hard right
like like I feel like Kevin I sitting up
here is just the same reason that him
and I are going to lose a lot of money
in angel investing for every Google
there's like a trillion other things
right Conway's first fun one in 187 miss
not 186 companies Google was the right
one in a way he went
I mean right when you talk about
business this stuff is hard everybody's
competing you know what you can do is be
good you know it's like like me sitting
up here and telling you like how do you
become an NBA basketball player well
[ __ ] you need a shitload of natural
talent and then you need to work your
[ __ ] face off your whole life to get
there so you want me to tell you how to
build a business figure out what you're
probably the best at then work until you
bleed directly out of your eyeballs and
then maybe you have a shot and I know
it's kind of like funny and silly but
it's kind of the truth like like nothing
for nothing
Ken and I cat was already internet
famous I really kind of wasn't when we
first started becoming friends we were
talking on a mat three in the morning
grinding yeah Gary my first met Gary we
were at FOA in London and he comes up to
me he's like hey I got this blindside
he's like and you want a case of wine I
can send you some wine let me know like
and I was like I don't know this guy it
was worse than that he's being nice to
me
Cairo speaks at belleau 7 I brought up
in my overt up in my talk it was the
first conference I ever went to I was so
pumped I come up to him he's in the
corner a bunch of people in front of him
and I'm like hey Kevin yeah I do this
white thing and my show once was on the
first page of Digg awesome and then I
got left like I really thought I I
actually thought you knew every story
that ever made the front page of dig
back that I truly thought that don't
forget I told you I wasn't techie right
like literally I had an e-commerce site
from 97 205 but literally I only started
paying attention to this space in like
2005 like I didn't know like your cover
on Businessweek came out before I even
knew about the dig I'm like
I came in so late like I truly thought
you knew but the cool thing is that like
that's where you started then you
started hustling after that you were
just meeting everyone you possibly could
like talking about like Ryan's gone oh
it was amazing
talking about just ways that you can get
yourself out there and start networking
like a lot of people I think Matt Van
Horn was speaking about this couple of
yesterday right just ways that you can
like grow a pair and go out there and
like make it happen it's guys check this
out so I come into this new space I have
a 50 million dollar business at this
point like I made it amongst my friends
like I've built the real thing like like
everybody thought I made it I come into
this space and I recognize and I think
this is a mistake a lot of people make
I knew my role I didn't come in and be
like oh you guys you don't need to make
money you're not good that's a big
mistake people made I said this is a new
space I got to start from zero the first
event I did after fella was I flew to
San Francisco and provided all the wine
paid for my own flight sent out $1,000
worth of wine which I had so that
between a different spot of maybe being
zero but to do a Leo Laporte guy coup
Meetup and I stood behind a table and
was a bartender and people like hey kid
fill this up for me like like I think
that people you want me to be honest
with you I think we're soft I think that
I think America's soft I really do I
think if you look at how we're handling
the global economy we just keep kicking
the can down the road shit's got to hit
the fan eventually it's math you know
there's nothing you know I think we're
soft I think people have a sense of
entitlement
I don't know [ __ ] that you read
TechCrunch for the last two years you
know what have you built you know like
so like III think they're sort of
obnoxious you know Ryan to answer the
question it takes real talent and then
your talent is gonna be somewhere right
like either you're good enough to do a
million-dollar company of 50 of 500 but
even if you're good enough to do a
million-dollar company which is a great
number an amazing accomplishment by the
way again this whole fascination that
you have to build a seven trillion
dollar business even if you're good
enough to build a million dollar company
you're gonna have to work your face off
like you just are you're gonna have to
work a lot it's work and a lot of people
are competing for that dollar and that
eyeball